I think let's go.
Who's calling from two four zero.
And where are you calling from?
[inaudible] this is Eric.
Hey Eric.
It's gone.
Yeah, I called you about three weeks.
All right.
So Eric, listen, something's going on with
your phone.
Every third word.
It sounds like you're underwater.
Is the, is there anything we might be able
to do about that?
Oh, okay.
No, just by myself.
Just barely, just barely.
Let's try, I'm going to, let's try it one
more time.
What was your question?
Um, I, I was saying I called you three weeks
ago.
Can you hear me?
Yes.
You call three weeks ago.
Okay.
I called you about three weeks ago and we
got into it about the Trump tower meeting
being ina setup.
And I saw that you posted it on your youtube
channel.
Do you remember that by any chance?
I know rings a bell.
It rings a bell.
Yeah.
Yes.
Um, um, hold on.
NBC News.
Uh, no.
Um, just being a letter, I guess you could
call it and says Trump dossier from which
is fusion gps also supplied info youth in
Trump tower meeting.
And the second paragraph says in an interview
with NBC News, Russian lawyer, Natalia [inaudible],
next guy.
Uh, since you received, suppose it incriminating
evidence for the Trump tower meeting, um,
fusion gps on a Glenn Simpson.
Okay.
And then you said I was disconnected from
reality and you hung up on me.
Okay.
What was, I don't, I don't remember the specifics
of the conversation.
I don't all, I also just am lacking the context
to know what the paragraph you read, how it
to what you're asserting, but if you email
it to me, I'll take a look at it.
Well, well, exactly.
To what I was asserting, I told you that it
was a setup, a fusion gps, which is a Democrat
party research firm.
And then I said that the lady was sent in
by fusion gps, Glenn Simpson, who was the
founder and the owner.
And you said, I'm disconnected from reality
and I can't walk and chew bubble gum at the
same time or something of that nature.
I, I that's not really a phrase that I use.
So the fact that you're attributing a phrase
like that to me makes me question your recollection
of it.
But listen, Eric, I don't know, remember exactly
what you're talking about and your audio is
going in and out.
So can you email me what you're talking about
and I'll look at it
apparently.
Okay.
Thank you.
I appreciate the call.
I will look at that and uh, we will research
and follow up.